zdf heute live herzlich willkommen die
pandemie ist alles andere als vorbei mit
diesen worten hat noch
gesundheitsminister sparen die lage
heute wohl leider ziemlich treffend
beschrieben denn die inzidenz zahlen
sind vielerorts wieder ziemlich hoch und
auch die krankenhäuser fühlen sich
allmählich wieder vor allem die
sogenannten booster impfungen müssen
jetzt vorangetrieben werden so hat es
sparen formuliert und impfstoff-experte
leif erik santer von der berliner
charité ergänzt rund 30 millionen
menschen müssten zeitnah eine
auffrischungsimpfung bekommen zum
hintergrund gerade sind es rund zwei
millionen gut zwei millionen die diese
auffrischung schon bekommen haben fazit
das tempo beim impfen ist zu langsam
gleichzeitig gehe nun wieder die
bundesländer voran verschärften ihre
maßnahmen darunter heute nach baden
württemberg auch hessen und bayern und
dabei geht es unter anderem auch um die
dritte impfung
wir müssen die drei impfungen in
deutschland bayern massiv voran bringen
der booster ist der beste schutz der
booster ist der beste schutz wärme in
israel eine situation gehabt dass dann
auch am anfang große erfolge waren durch
viel impfen dann viel israel wieder
zurück weil ansteckung und waren und mit
der tritt impfung ist es jetzt gelungen
die zahlen wieder deutlich nach unten zu
bringen deswegen sind wir der festen
überzeugung nicht nur der impfung für
über 70-jährige sondern im grunde
genommen jedem zu ermöglichen der eine
solche zweitimpfung hatte wenn die sechs
monate vorbei sind mit dem rad noch ein
antikörpertest zu machen um selber
nochmal einzuschätzen wie die lage ist
aber generell ist eine grippeimpfung aus
sicht von bayern für jeden sinnvoll
wo es medizinisch möglich ist über die
hausärzte oder im zweifelsfall erfahren
die impfzentren das wird vom
gesundheitsminister noch geklärt ich
selber wird auch weil wir jetzt auch
deshalb ist ja er ist nicht auch relativ
bald ein drittes mal impfen lassen
das klingt nach bus der impfung für alle
aber ist das überhaupt so reibungslos
möglich oder droht eventuell ein neues
chaos wie gehen wir die vierte welle an
darüber sprechen wir jetzt in wenigen
minuten mit frau professor christine
falk sie ist präsidentin der deutschen
gesellschaft für immunologie und zuvor
und zwar jetzt und gleich mit dem
bayerischen gesundheitsminister klaus
holetschek einen schönen guten abend
herr neudeck
guten abend ja wir haben gerade ihren
regierungschef markus söder gehört er
sagt am ende wird jeder eine booster
impfung in anspruch nehmen müssen ist
das auch in ihren augen der königsweg
aus der pandemie
es ist zumindest glaube ich ein weg um
weiter erfolgreich in der pandemie
agieren zu können dass instant ist
tatsächlich der weg aus der pandemie und
wir merken ja dass jetzt die
immunantwort vielleicht schwächer wird
bei dem ein oder anderen und deswegen
ist die auffrischungsimpfung glaube ich
schon ein ganz wichtiges instrument wir
sprechen gleich weiter herr hologic aber
wir hatten schon mal fest das tempo ist
ein problem beim impfen darüber sind
sich eigentlich alle experten einig und
das betrifft nicht nur das boostern das
auch aber auch die erstimpfung und dazu
sehen wir jetzt gerade noch mal ein paar
fakten
rein statistisch bekommen pro sekunde
knapp zwei menschen in deutschland eine
spritze gegen das corona virus klingt
viel ist aber deutlich weniger als im
sommer die impfkampagne in deutschland
stockt und das seit wochen gestern
wurden 196 1000 dosen verabreicht und
umfragen zeigen die meisten die bis
jetzt noch nicht geimpft wurden haben
das auch in nächster zeit nicht vor
55,6 millionen menschen haben es getan
und sind vollständig geimpft das
entspricht 66,8 prozent der
gesamtbevölkerung booster also
auffrischungsimpfungen haben bislang 22
millionen menschen erhalten
die ständige impfkommission empfiehlt
sie bislang nur für bestimmte gruppen
für menschen ab 70 6 monate nach der
letzten spritze für alle die mit johnson
& johnson geimpft wurden für wohl nahe
gruppen wie in altenheim für
medizinisches und pflegepersonal
einen booster für alle jetzt sofort hält
die stiko für nicht praktikabel und
unnötig
und immunisiert
mittleren alter sich finden die können
tatsächlich davon ausging dass sie jetzt
noch ausreichenden schutz von der
grundimmunisierung für schwere
erkrankungen haben
also professor mertens von der stiko
spricht sich für eine klare
priorisierung aus alles andere sei
unpraktikabel und unnötig decken sich
denn ihre pläne für bayern mit den
empfehlungen der stiko
also die stiko ist sicherlich ein
wichtiger verband der sich da immer
wieder äußert wissenschaftlich
unabhängige und wir hören auch auf die
stiko aber ich glaube dass neben den
empfehlungen der stiko die booster
impfung für alle die es dann auch
brauchen die vielleicht einen
antikörpertest auch vorher gemacht haben
schon wichtig und richtig ist und wir
müssen da aus meiner sicht auch
geschwindigkeit aufnehmen um vor die
lage zu kommen ich frage sie auch
deshalb nach ihren plänen weil es auch
durchaus kritik seitens der ärzte gibt
wenn sich die politik sozusagen von den
vorschlägen der stiko entfernt diese
kritik gibt es unter anderem auch von
kassenärzte chef andreas gassen haben
wir da auch noch mal kurz rein wir
können das die rahmenbedingungen müssen
stimmen und politik hilft unseren denken
tatsächlich am besten wenn diese
rahmenbedingungen geschaffen werden und
die regel nicht alle paar wochen
behindert werden und für uns für die
nähe dessen ärzte ist halt die
entscheidung und die empfehlungen der
ständigen impfkommission die auf die wir
uns verlassen die basiert auf
wissenschaftlichen der datenanalyse und
abweichende empfehlung wie gut gemeint
sie auch immer sein mögen kürzeren daher
können sie diese kritik nachvollziehen
denn es gibt ja durchaus auch
niedergelassene ärzte die sagen dass die
erwartungshaltung die von der politik
geführt wird dass jetzt jeder überall
schon eine impfung bekommen können die
kann von den ärzten so gar nicht
aufgefangen werden
also ich teile nicht immer die meinung
von den kassen in dem fall auch nicht
ich glaube wir können mit den ärzten
gemeinsam das gut hinkriegen dass in den
bayern jeden mittwoch in einer
steuerungsgruppe mit hausärzten
fachärzten der ärztekammer der
kassenärztlichen vereinigung und
unterhalten uns darüber was sinnvoll und
wichtig ist in der pandemie bekämpfung
wir wollen ja nicht gegen jemand was
machen sondern miteinander die
impfzentren und die ärzte zb wenn
notwendig ist können das glaube ich
leisten und wir müssen natürlich auch
klare botschaften aussenden wir müssen
eine klare kommunikation haben das war
leider in der pandemie des öfteren immer
schwierig diese kommunikation denken sie
an astrazeneca und andere themen
deswegen werbe ich dafür dass gemeinsam
anzugehen es gibt eine zulassung für die
booster impfung das muss man ja vorneweg
mal sagen ihm stoffe die zugelassen sind
und von daher glaube ich stehen wir da
nicht in einer konkurrenz jetzt zur
stiko sondern in einer konkurrenz zum
brechen einer vierten welle die gerade
mit voller wucht auf uns zukommt nicola
bilanz ihrer fans über youtube ich
stelle mir die frage was wenn man schon
zwei mal geimpft wurde und jetzt die
dritte impfung verweigert ist man dann
wieder mensch zweiter klasse und eine
gefahr für das öffentliche zusammenleben
also so empfindet er oder sie das wohl
nein ich glaube darum geht es im moment
nicht es geht ja darum menschen zu
schützen deren immunantwort vielleicht
schwächer ist es geht darum die älteren
menschen zu schützen wo wir wissen dass
die immunantwort vielleicht nachlässt
die auch andere vorerkrankungen schon
haben das ist sinn und zweck dieser
frage der auffrischungsimpfung wir
wollen ja gemeinsam durch diese pandemie
und diesen winter gut durchkommen und
ich glaube dass es einfach notwendig
dass wir darüber nachdenken und auch
gemeinsam beraten wie wir das am besten
bewerkstelligen können trotzdem ist die
organisation des ganzen prozesses
natürlich eine herausforderung wie die
impfungen in den bundesländern
organisiert werden könnten auch dazu hat
sich heute nochmal der
bundesgesundheitsminister geäußert wenn
zu viele impfwillige finden aktuell kein
arzt der sie impft das ist das was uns
täglich berichtet wird auch dort finde
ich müssen wir gemeinsam mit der
ärzteschaft zu einem auflösen kommen und
deshalb möchte ich auch gerne dass die
länder ihre öffentlichen impf angebote
wieder auf und ausbauen das müssen nicht
die zentralen großen impfzentren sein
es können auch natürlich dezentralere
kleinere anlaufstellen seien wichtig ist
aber dieses öffentliche angebot noch da
will ich darauf hinweisen am 28 juni
haben wir in der
gesundheitsministerkonferenz miteinander
vereinbart punkt 2 a in dem beschluss
dass eben diese öffentlichen angebote in
den standby betrieb gehen und bei bedarf
zügig wieder hoch gefahren werden können
und diesen bedarf sehen wir eben aktuell
wenn es um die auffrischimpfung geht
ja da stellt sich natürlich die frage
wie sieht das denn konkret in bayern aus
sind in ihre impfzentren noch im standby
modus und könnten sie die jederzeit
wieder hochfahren
also wir haben 81 impfzentren in bayern
im standby modus über 240 mobile teams
die jetzt vorliegenden altenheimen und
pflegeheimen waren um dort die booster
impfungen durchzuführen und wir können
die natürlich weiter hochfahren das ist
möglich wir wollen das aber zusammen mit
den ärzten machen dort wo es notwendig
ist dass wir kapazitäten zur verfügung
stellen sind wir gerne bereit auch die
impfzentren wieder aufstand zu bringen
dort wo die ärzte sagen wir schaffen das
auch weil genügend potenzial da ist kann
man das gemeinsam auch anders ausrichten
wichtig ist dass man da hand in hand
arbeitet da haben mit sicherheit die
ärzte auch nichts dagegen jetzt ist es
so die instanzen sind gerade auch in
teilen bayerns sehr hoch der landkreis
miesbach ist aktuell spitzenreiter in
deutschland
682 und von den 500 entschuldigung von
den 25 bundesweiten corona hotspots der
liegen laut markus söder 16 in bayern
woran liegt das und was wollen sie
dagegen tun
naja das thema der inzidenz der
steigenden ist natürlich schon einst das
beachtung finden muss wir haben uns ja
eigentlich vom leid indikator instituts
verabschiedet und trotzdem ist er ein
seismograph auch für das was in den
krankenhäusern sich abspielt aber das
ist ja das entscheidende dort wo die
krankenhäuser volllaufen die
intensivstationen wieder voll sind dort
müssen wir handeln das haben wir jetzt
auch getan und deswegen versuchen wir
diese neuinfektionen die mit einer
unglaublichen dynamik im moment kommen
auch wieder zurückzudrängen wir haben an
der grenze eine besondere situation die
hatten wir immer in der pandemie auch
durch einpendeln und andere geschehnisse
und dort wo die impfquote tatsächlich
niedriger ist merkt man natürlich auch
dass die neuinfektionen rausgehen ja das
war jetzt sozusagen da der blick auf
bayern wenn man das jetzt mal insgesamt
auf deutschland bezieht denn das ist
natürlich immer gut wenn wir hier ein
vertreter aus der politik haben die
frage stellt sich momentan jeder warum
sind wir denn mit dem impfen so langsam
gerade auch im internationalen vergleich
also andere nationen wie zum beispiel
israel aber auch großbritannien sind da
wesentlich schneller woran liegt das
ihrer meinung nach nicht
denkt ist ein unterschiedliches system
vielleicht müssen wir auch die menschen
noch besser überzeugen wir merken ja
dass das impfen jetzt sehr zäh ist wir
wissen auch dass es leute gibt die sich
im moment nicht mehr mit argumenten auch
befassen es ist sicherlich auch nicht
hilfreich wenn gewisse prominente in der
öffentlichkeit sagen sie lassen sich
nicht impfen weil sie langzeitfolgen
befürchten dass solche dinge tagen
natürlich zu einer verunsicherung bei
deswegen werbe ich dafür dass wir alle
register noch mal ziehen die menschen zu
überzeugen dass das impfen der weg aus
der pandemie sich sagt immer es ist wie
ein elfmeter wo der ball am
elfmeterpunkt ist und das tor ist leer
das ist tatsächlich der weg beim impfen
aus der pandemie sehen sie dennoch
chancen weil sie gerade auch davon
gesprochen haben die impfwilligen zu
erreichen denn davon gibt es ja auch
noch eine ganze menge
ich glaube schon dass wir den ein oder
anderen noch mitnehmen können gott sei
dank finden ja jeden tag noch
erstimpfungen stadt aber viel zu wenig
natürlich es gibt auch menschen die
vielleicht noch auf einen anderen
impfstoff warten obwohl die da sind ja
sehr gut sind uns sicher also da gibt es
noch schon denkt gibt es ein oder andere
was bewegung mit rein bringt vielleicht
auch dass das ich sage auf den
intensivstationen sind vorwiegend
ungeimpfte menschen und die pflegekräfte
verzweifeln wirklich manchmal wenn sie
sagen der müsste eigentlich gar nicht da
sein wenn es sich hätte impfen lassen
können und das ist tatsächlich das
wichtige thema wenn ich mich impfen
lassen kann sollte dies tun nicht nur
für mich sondern auch um solche
situationen für die pflegekräfte und für
die ärzte zu vermeiden vielen dank klaus
holetschek war dass der
gesundheitsminister in bayern dankeschön
dass sie heute abend sich unseren fragen
gestellt haben und ich wünsche ihnen
alles gute wir sprechen gleich weiter
und zwar mit frau jetzt habe ich gerade
den namen vergessen entschuldigung mit
frau professor
christine falk entschuldigung genau mit
der geht es gleich weiter ja das ist
manchmal gar nicht so einfach die ganzen
namen auseinanderzuhalten genau wir
sprechen darüber dass es natürlich noch
einige faktoren gibt die jetzt zu
beachten sind auch jetzt gerade in
dieser zeit
beunruhigend nimmt er immer noch hohen
zahl der geimpften der ungeimpften sind
ja auch immer neue meldungen von
sogenannten durchbrüchen was das ist und
warum man deswegen trotzdem nicht auf
eine weitere impfung verzichten sollte
dazu jetzt mehr
vollständig geimpft und trotzdem
erkrankt immer wieder kommt es zu
sogenannten emv durchbrüchen das rk ii
zählt seit anfang februar fast 118000
wahrscheinliche fälle also corona
infektionen mit symptomen sehr selten
kommt es zu schweren verläufen
auf deutschen krankenstationen sind
zurzeit 32 prozent der kurve patienten
geimpft auf den intensivstationen sind
es 25 prozent bei den über 60 jährigen
liegen diese zahlen noch höher
dass die korona impfung nicht wirkt
zeigt das aber nicht denn es handelt
sich immer noch um sehr sehr wenige
fälle im vergleich zur gesamtzahl an
geimpften und um eine logische
konsequenz mit steigender impfquote
steigt auch die zahl der impf
durchbrüche
das lka hat berechnet dass für geimpfte
jüngere der schutz vor einer schweren
cupid erkrankung bei 90 prozent liege
bei über 60-jährigen betrage die
wirksamkeit 85 prozent und vor einem
krankheitsverlauf der so schwer ist dass
man auf die intensivstation muss schütze
die impfung zu 94 prozent und zu 91
prozent bei älteren und
dieses thema ist geradezu ideal geeignet
um es mit unserem nächsten gast zu
besprechen deren name ich jetzt
natürlich nicht mehr vergessen werde
also es handelt sich um frau professor
christine falk biologin an der
medizinischen hochschule hannover und
präsidentin der deutschen gesellschaft
für immunologie langer titel einen
schönen guten abend frau professor falk
schon dass sie bei uns sind dynamisch
prüfen bevor wir gleich auf eine grafik
zu sprechen kommen die sie uns
freundlicherweise zur verfügung gestellt
haben anhand derer sich das mit den impf
durchbrüchen auch noch mal gut erklären
lässt vielleicht noch mal kurz vorweg
gefragt beunruhigt sie als expertin die
vermeintliche hohe zahl von imf
durchbrüchen im moment
als immunologin bedrückt mich das gar
nicht weil wir seit wir immunreaktionen
messe können immer schon leute haben die
sehr gut auf eine antwort reagieren und
sehr hohe antikörper zum beispiel
produzieren und andere die nicht ganz so
gut reagieren und in dieser ganzen
bandbreite bewegt sich dann auch die
frage wie gut die menschen individuell
geschützt sind und dass es im
durchbrüche geben würde war auch in den
zulassungsstudien schon klar dass es
sehr sehr wenige sein würden war auch
klar und je mehr menschen wir impfen das
haben sie gerade im beitrag gesagt desto
höher ist auch die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass solche menschen sich dann trotz
impfung anstecken können weil sie keinen
so ganz ohne impfschutz haben denn nimmt
mit der zeit etwas ab können wir nachher
noch besprechen das hat auch eine alters
komponente wie wir gerade schon gehört
haben und deswegen ist es nichts
ungewöhnliches auch noch nichts
beunruhigendes die frage ist nur was
können wir tun um die aktuelle welle die
wir haben zu begrenzen und zu verhindern
dass das virus sich ausbreitet weil es
sich ja hauptsächlich in der gruppe der
ungeimpften personen ausbreitet und dann
erwischt quasi noch ein paar geimpfte
personen leider mit beides sollten dir
am besten verhindern oder soweit
reduzieren wie es irgend geht und dann
gehen wir doch mal in die details also
sie haben uns was mitgebracht
tatsächlich das sie sonst in ihren
vorlesungen dem die halten sie auch noch
verwenden das ist eine kleine analogie
zum fußball kann man sagen mit dem sich
das thema durchbrüche aber dann sehr
anschaulich auch erklären lässt und ich
würde sagen dann lege ich ihnen quasi
jetzt manche den ball auf den punkt und
sie dürfen dann gerne übernehmen und
erklären uns was es damit auf sich hat
also diese idee kam übrigens beim
endspiel england gegen italien als
elfmeterschießen stattfand und wir alle
ganz gespannt worden wie das wohl
ausgehen würde habe ich mir gedacht das
könnte man ja vielleicht nutzen wenn man
nicht geimpft ist dann ist das wie eine
elfmetersituation ohne torwart weil
einfach gar keinen schutz teil es kein
mensch hat dieses virus vorhergesehen
die ganze bevölkerung war letztes jahr
zum beispiel diesen bier virus
tatsächlich schutzlos ausgeliefert das
ist dann so wie der elfmeter der 100
prozent verwandelt wird wenn die leute
sich infizieren kann das virus
tatsächlich sich ausbreiten und bei
wenigen fällen war es immer schon so
dass es dann doch schwere fälle gab und
auch menschen die eben ins krankenhaus
mussten und auf die intensivstation
das ist die situation wenn man nicht
geimpft ist wie eben ein bisschen wieder
elfmeter ohne torwart okay das wäre
sozusagen also das perfekte spiel fällt
für das virus was wäre dahin die nächste
stufe
die nächste stufe wäre die impfung und
wenn man sich dann vorstellen wie man
das übersetzen könnte in die fußball
situation dann haben wir eine impf
situation die menschen haben
idealerweise zwei mal eine impfdosis
bekommen sie bilden antikörper und sind
dadurch schon mal sehr gut geschützt und
die antikörper sind quasi unsere erste
abwehrfront und die steht dann wie die
abwehr in der freistoßsituation eine
geschlossene abwehr und das virus der
ball kommt gar nicht durch weil die
antikörper es sofort abfangen verhindern
dass das virus überhaupt in den körper
und in die zellen hinein kommen kann
dann habe ich zwar die zellen sind
sozusagen das tor dann hinten ich habe
dann zwar noch meine t zellen durch die
impfung die brauche ich aber in dem
moment gar nicht wenn das virus gar
nicht so weit kommt zellen zu infizieren
das ist die situation die wir bei den
allermeisten menschen den über 55
millionen menschen in deutschland die
doppelt geimpft sind tatsächlich
vorfinden oder antikörper die schützen
davor dass das virus überhaupt in die
zelle und in den körper gelangt wir
hätten aber zur not noch dann die
t-zellen falls es notwendig wird und
dass es sozusagen dann die nächste
situation die idealsituation ist
wirklich die komplett davor geschützt zu
sein dass man sich ansteckt und wir
wissen eben dass es menschen gibt die
entweder älter sind oder medikamente
nehmen müssen die das immunsystem
beeinträchtigen oder wo die impfung
einfach schon sehr viel länger
zurückliegt und da bekommt diese
abwehrfront löcher und dann kann man
sich so vorstellen dass zwei antikörper
da sind aber die verhindern nicht mehr
komplett dass wenn das virus in den
nasen-rachen-raum gepostet wird dass man
wirklich komplett geschützt ist und dann
kann das virus in die zellen gelangen
hier im nasen-rachen-raum aber trotzdem
dass wir ein quasi die durchbruchs
infektionen aber trotzdem hat das
immunsystem bereits einen vorsprung sich
erarbeitet durch die impfung wir haben
nämlich dann die t zellen als zweite
abwehrfront nur die sitzen nicht gleich
oben weil die patroullieren durch den
körper und die müssen erst rekrutiert
werden und die kommen dann ins spiel
wenn eine er infiziert ist und der
körper versucht zu verhindern dass das
virus sich dann noch ausbreitet und
deswegen haben wir da diese großen t
zellen im tor die kontrollieren dann die
weitere virus ausbreitung das sind dann
durchbruchs infektionen die aber im
normalfall lange nicht so schwer
verlaufen wie wenn jemand eben nicht
geimpft ist und deswegen sind das auch
meistens sehr leichte verläufe und es
gibt wirklich sehr sehr wenige die dann
doch noch ins krankenhaus müssen oder
auch auf intensivstationen landen das
sind auch meistens ältere menschen die
noch andere probleme auch immunologische
probleme haben aber dass wir sozusagen
die situation eines im durchbruchs durch
dann wenn wir jetzt gerade bei der frage
der booster impfung bleiben ja dann
könnte man sagen wenn man jetzt den
durchbruch zu befürchten hat dann kann
man durch eine booster impfung wieder
die geschlossene abwehrkette hervorrufen
weil man einfach durch diese dritte
booster impfung die antikörper noch mal
erhöht und dadurch erreichen kann dass
die abwehrfront wieder ganz geschlossen
steht und vielleicht kann man mit diesem
fußball beispiel so ein bisschen
erklären wie dieses komplizierte
immunsystem funktioniert und wo wir
gerade stehen und warum wir auch gerade
diskutieren für wen und warum und wann
es schon sinnvoll wäre brewster
impfungen an ja also ich fand es auch
sehr anschaulich also da war alles dabei
von elfmeter ohne torwart bis hin zu
geschlossener mauer mit weltklasse
keeper sozusagen noch hinten dran aber
woher weiß ich denn jetzt als patient
als möglicher über welche defensive ich
verfüge also auch mal gibt's ja
zumindest wenn ich geimpft bin große
unterschiede
es gibt große unterschiede aber die
wegen bewegen sich echt auf einem sehr
hohen niveau es ist wirklich so dass wie
exzellent gut die impfstoffe die wir in
deutschland zugelassen haben wirken
sieht man daran dass die allermeisten
menschen diese sehr hohe geschlossene
abwehrkette tatsächlich haben und das
gilt vor allem für die leute die unter
70 jahre sind gesund sind ein
funktionierendes immunsystem haben das
wurde gemessen in großen
zulassungsstudien in hunderten
publikationen in ganz viel in den
unikliniken und den labors in
deutschland bei uns auch da sieht man
wirklich dass nach der zweiten impfung
eine sehr gute antikörper abwehrkette
steht wie eine eins also im prinzip kann
man wirklich sagen die impfung wirkt so
gut dass die allermeisten menschen die
sich gesund fühlen gesundes immunsystem
haben wirklich diesen exzellenten
impfschutz haben und deswegen ist die
empfehlung der stiko übrigens auch
goldrichtig für diesen moment und dieser
moment heißt herbst winter weil wir uns
wirklich darauf konzentrieren sollten
menschen über 70 und menschen die ein
eingeschränktes immunsystem haben oder
eben menschen die im pflegedienst oder
im krankenhaus arbeiten um uns auf die
zu konzentrieren und im moment dafür zu
ermöglichen dass möglichst schnell und
möglichst effizient eine dritte booster
impfung zur verfügung gestellt wird weil
das sind die die es wirklich brauchen
also klagen anderen damen sorgen sagen
ja der impfschutz ist gut es braucht man
nicht zwingend ok verstehe user frage
von shanghai nun weiß man denn schon
genaueres über die von ihnen gerade
angesprochene vorhandene t-zellen
immunität in der bevölkerung wenn ja zu
welchem anteil ist diese vorhanden
also antikörper kann man sehr einfach
messen bei t zellen ist es komplizierter
technisch schwieriger und auch viel
aufwendiger aber es gibt große studien
und sehr viele publikationen die zeigen
wenn immer eine antikörper antwort da
ist habe ich auch eine t zell antwort
das kennen wir von allen immunreaktionen
die wir haben das immunsystem was so
eine kaskade so eine kettenreaktion und
da kommen die antikörper und die tat
seien parallel weil es ein sehr
kompliziertes räderwerk ist und am ende
dieser impfreaktion kommen diese beiden
abwehr säulen dieses immunsystems zum
tragen antikörper und t zellen immer
parallel also wenn jemand antikörper
gebildet hat hat er t zellen und
deswegen sind diese beiden partner des
immunsystems immer parallel aktiviert
wenn man die menschen im kiez ausnahmen
das kann man vielleicht dann noch
besprechen bei menschen bei denen zum
beispiel die b zellen nicht mehr aktiv
sein dürfen weil sie zum beispiel eine
tumorerkrankung haben oder eine
krebserkrankung dann ist es so ohne
b-zellen bekommt man keine antikörper
die produzieren die antikörper das ist
wie in diesem wunderbaren film ziemlich
beste freunde keine arme keine
schokolade keine b zellen keine
antikörper trotzdem sind die t zellen
aber da das heißt diese beiden partner
gehen normalerweise immer zusammen sie
können aber auch einzeln wenn es denn
sein muss aber idealerweise bei uns
allen wenn wir sie mal sagen wir sind
alle so gesund haben wir immer beide
partner parallel also kann man davon
ausgehen denn antikörper da sind sind
auch t zellen dar ich lese gerade noch
mal ein paar user stimmen vor potsdam 86
über youtube schreibt solange es noch
keine stiko empfehlung gibt werde ich
erst einmal abwarten hoffe aber
weiterhin dass bei uns in der stadt das
impfzentrum noch offen bleibt also
offenbar ist er noch nicht in der gruppe
die jetzt aufgefordert ist sich diese
dritte impfung abzuholen mary derweil 08
schreibt warum braucht die stiko immer
so lang und hinkt hinterher siehe
frankreich usa wo sollen die kinder
schneller geimpft werden haben sie auch
den eindruck dass die stiko bei uns
lange braucht
also bei der stiko muss man wirklich
wissen dass deren arbeitsweise sehr
davon abhängt wie die studienlage ist
die sind also nicht langsam sondern die
sind ganz besonders genau und sie
arbeiten auch anders als wir wenn wir
eine publikation lesen dann können wir
innerhalb von einem tag das ding
durchlesen und haben einen guten
eindruck was da passiert die stiko hat
ein sehr definiertes vorgehen und diese
frage welche evidenz gibt es für eine
empfehlung die hat verschiedene stufen
und es liegt also nicht daran dass jetzt
die stiko langsam wäre sondern die stiko
fordert das höchste evidenz niveau für
die einführung zum beispiel einen neuen
impfung und wenn die studien dieses
evidenz niveau und es hat sehr viel mit
studienplanung und mit der
zuverlässigkeit dieser studien zu tun
wenn das geprüft wird und sozusagen das
höchste evidenz niveau erreicht ist dann
ist die stiko auch in der lage
empfehlungen auszusprechen also sind die
nicht wirklich langsam das kann man so
nicht sagen sondern die arbeiten sehr
gründlich und nach sehr gut vorgegebenen
maß vorgaben die uns alle davor schützen
dass etwas zugelassen wird was eben
nicht diesen hohen standards entspricht
ob dieses vorgehen das in normalzeiten
sozusagen der goldstandard ist ob das
immer die allerbeste variante ist wenn
wir ein der pandemie haben ist natürlich
eine frage die dieses spannungsfeld
zwischen geschwindigkeit und sehr genau
analysieren und bewerten natürlich
beinhaltet und dadurch entsteht
vielleicht der eindruck dass die langsam
sind aber sie sind halt auch wirklich
extrem bewusst auf diese
qualitätsstandards bezogen vielleicht
erklärt es so ein bisschen warum der
eindruck entsteht dass die zögerlich
sind in anderen ländern sind die zum
teil auch strukturell anders aufgestellt
und deswegen erscheint es da schneller
und insofern kann man schon auch sagen
das ist schon auch gut dass wir uns auf
die stiko verlassen können der pandemie
modus ist etwas was vielleicht auch noch
etwas ist wo man so ein bisschen
überlegen kann ob man es nicht doch mit
einbeziehen kann in diese überlegungen
ich kann an dieser stelle nur ein lob
für sie aussprechen also zum einen von
mir ich finde das ganz toll die das
erklären aber das sieht auch karin
kaspar exo sie schreibt uns über youtube
die professoren erklärt das sehr gut und
für alle verständlich vielen dank für
ihre arbeit eine weitere user frage kann
man durch impfen dieselbe immunität
erreichen wie durch eine natürlich
erworbene infektionen gibt es da
unterschiede auch bezüglich der t-zellen
klar gibt es da unterschiede und zwar
deshalb was so ein bisschen unter geht
in der diskussion ist das geniale an der
impfung ist was brauchen wir zum impfen
nur diese stachel proteinen dieses bei
proteinen ist aus diesem corona virus
wie so ein krönchen oben immer
ausgebucht und wir brechen quasi dem
virus in sachen aus der krone das ist
das einzige von diesem virus was wir als
impfstoff verwenden entweder den mba
oder vector impfstoff mehr brauchen wir
nicht also macht unser körper auch nur
gegen dieses bike oder stachel protein
antikörper und t-zellen mehr braucht es
nicht wenn ich aber jetzt eine infektion
habe dann habe ich das ganze virus im
nasen-rachen-raum drin das frisst sich
dann je nachdem wie gut mein körper das
kontrollieren kann tiefer in die lunge
runter hoffentlich nicht so tief das
sind dann die leichten fälle und dieses
virus hat natürlich noch ein dutzend
andere proteine und nicht nur der
stachel protein weil viren sind halt
generell weltmeister im täuschen und
tarnen wenn die erstmal in der 2 alle
drin sind dann programmieren sie die
zelle um und sagen egal was du gestern
gemacht hast ab morgen virus produktion
und unser körper macht und auch
antikörper gegen diese vielen vielen
proteine dieses virus also sieht die
immunantwort ganz anders aus da gibt es
ganz viele antikörper gegen viele
strukturen die helfen aber nicht so
wirklich weil sie ja dem virus immer
hinterherlaufen
bei der impfung hat man den
riesenvorteil dass die antikörper und
die these hingegen stachel protein schon
vorher da sind und sofort dieses neue
proteinen im falle einer infektion
erkennen und wie wir es wollen bei dem
fußball beispiel gezeigt haben
idealerweise schon komplett verhindern
dass man sich überhaupt an steckt also
die immunantwort ist natürlich eine
andere auf eine infektion aber man
braucht nicht denken das ist jetzt
besser wäre sich zu infizieren auf gar
keinen fall weil das virus ist ein
echter feind im körper den wenn man am
besten gar nicht gesehen dann auch mit
großen wenn man ihn haben will dann
lässt man sich am allerbesten impfen
verstehe es da wo es david wir kriegen
jetzt unheimlich viele zuschriften ich
bin sehr dankbar dass wir sie hier haben
dass sie die beantworten können wieso
müssen die geimpften und genesenen sich
nicht mehr testen somit verbreitet sich
doch das virus und ist eine gefahr für
die gesellschaft beziehungsweise für
risikogruppen anstatt dass wir das virus
kontrollieren können
diese empfehlung stammt aus zeiten im
sommer wir erinnern uns als wir sehr
niedrige infektionszahlen hatten und wie
er davon ausgehen konnten dass endlich
genügend impfstoff da ist dass sehr
viele menschen sich hoffentlich impfen
lassen und das mit dieser impfung oder
eben die menschen die genesen sind da
kein risiko besteht sich anzustecken und
weil man sich nicht ansteckt dann hat
man auch keine virus weitergabe das war
also eine völlig logische folgerung aus
der sommerphase heraus und des lka hat
bereits im juli ein szenario für
vorbereitung auf herbst winter
veröffentlicht das ist so ein bisschen
untergegangen ich glaube da war so ein
bisschen wahlkampf dazwischen da hatten
wir was anderes im kopf wir haben aber
damals schon sehr genau gesagt wenn wir
nicht über 75 prozent der bevölkerung
impfen dann haben wir viel zu viele
menschen die sich noch anstecken können
und dann steigen die zahlen dann werden
sich unter umständen auch geimpfte mit
dem kontakt zu menschen die infiziert
sind das virus einfangen die werden
vielleicht nicht selber krank aber die
können es dann doch noch zwar kurze zeit
23 tage aber vielleicht doch noch
weitergeben das ist genau die situation
die wir haben leider zu viele menschen
die nicht geimpft sind die sich
anstecken die zahlen gehen wo und die
kollateral infektion wenn man so will
trifft dann geimpfte und die können es
weiter geben und aus dieser logik heraus
würde man sagen ja es wäre jetzt besser
wenn man geimpfte und genesene doch
testen würde je nachdem was für eine
veranstaltung man vorhat weil man eben
nicht mehr ausschließen kann dass die
doch noch virus mitschleppen und
infektiös sind das risiko ist zwar
geringer aber es ist halt nicht neu im
moment haben wir wirklich eine phase wo
man am besten sein hirn einschaltet wie
man in bayern meiner heimat sagen würde
und versucht klug zu überlegen was habe
ich für eine veranstaltung vor wie gehe
ich damit um und wie halte ich das
risiko möglichst gering dass ich halt
auch menschen dort anstecken und
deswegen würde man heute die empfehlung
schon ein bisschen in richtung mehr test
mit
aufgenommen haben wir das auch geklärt
hirn einschalten übrigens immer nur gute
idee nicht nur in bayern per mail kommt
an uns die frage von britta schulze mich
würde interessieren weil boost dann ist
ja das eigentliche thema ob die bisher
verwendeten impfstoffe auf die bekannten
mutationen zb die delta variante
angepasst und überarbeitet wurden macht
denn ohne diese anpassung eine booster
impfung überhaupt sinn
sie macht sind und zwar deshalb weil wir
noch mal diese staffel protein anschauen
ist man überall sieht bei den vielen
darstellungen bis ios dann hat es eine
ganz lange kette wie so eine perlenkette
die so wunderschön gefaltet ist und
diese perlenkette hat
1273 perlen
und davon sind immer noch über 1200 also
über 90 prozent identisch zwischen den
ursprungsvirus und dann alpha dazwischen
und jetzt älter das bedeutet wir werden
mit der ursprung sich
fans und dieser faltung diesem schönen
protein geimpft und machen antikörper
dagegen deswegen erkennen die auch sehr
gut noch die delta variante es gibt auch
ein paar antikörper die sind sozusagen
nicht mehr so gut in der lage genau
diese data variante zu sehen deswegen
ist der impfschutz nicht ganz so hoch
aber generell ist unsere sogenannte
grundimmunisierung mit der ursprungs
variante immer noch sehr wirksam gegen
data die durchbrüche sind halt auch die
leute die ausgerechnet gegen diese data
variante nicht mehr so alle antikörper
in dieser abwehrkette stehen haben dann
entstehen als ein paar löcher und wenn
es dadurch kommt kann es noch infizieren
aber generell kann man sagen unser glück
ist dass diese struktur sehr konserviert
ist und sich auch nicht komplett
verändern kann weil dann kann das virus
gar nicht mehr infizieren und es nicht
in seinem interesse dass während unserem
interesse aber nicht im interesse des
virus ja verstehen ein weiterer aspekt
sind natürlich auch die nebenwirkungen
auch in den vergangenen tagen vielfach
diskutiert worden auch bei unseren usern
da gibt es auch einige kommentare die
sagen die nebenwirkungen waren wir nach
den ersten beiden impfungen schon zu
krassen booster impfung will ich nicht
ist diesmal fragt uns über youtube gibt
es denn schon studien zu nebenwirkungen
bei booster impfungen
ja auch die gibt es es gibt jetzt gerade
eine große studie die wurde
veröffentlicht aus israel der waren
700.000 menschen beteiligt die eine
dritte impfung bekommen haben es gibt
auch aus england bereits studien und die
zeigen dass die dritte impfung nicht
mehr direkte wirkungen in den ersten ein
zwei tagen hat als die erste und die
zweite auch man merkt halt wenn das
immunsystem aktiv ist es spürt man halt
und manche leute mehr manche weniger
aber im prinzip merkt man halt dass die
aktivität passiert aber es ist nicht zu
erwarten aus diesen daten die wir da
kennen aus anderen ländern das jetzt bei
einer dritten impfung die wirkung noch
stärker wäre auch da hilft einfach wenn
man sich überlegt wann würde ich mir
denn die dritte impfung geben lassen
vielleicht nicht am nächsten tag wenn
ich eine prüfung habe oder ähnliche
dinge mehr und einen wichtigen
beruflichen terminen das macht dann
nicht so viel sinn ich habe das als wir
selber erlebt das war nicht so schlau
das ist ein echt anstrengend liegt schon
da wo es anstrengend kann man vielleicht
besser
planen weil man vielleicht doch einen
tag einfach ein bisschen platt ist aber
man erholt sich in der regel schnell und
es gibt jeden monat vom
paul-ehrlich-institut einen
sicherheitsbericht über sämtliche
meldung der imk nebenwirkungen da kann
man sehr genau nachlesen was hier in
deutschland passiert und was alles
gemeldet wird und daran kann man auch
ablesen wie sicher die impfstoffe sind
übrigens conny von kamp fragt uns per
mail ist denn bei der dritten impfung
die gefahr für herz entzündungen also
herzmuskelentzündung mainz sicher oder
seltener autoimmunerkrankungen höher
das ist eine sehr wichtige frage weil
wir gesehen haben dass gerade bei
jüngeren menschen und ihr bei jüngeren
männern es eine höhere
wahrscheinlichkeit wenngleich sehr wenig
ungefähr 1 in 25.000 wenn ich das
richtig im kopf haben dass eine herbst
muskel oder eine herzbeutelentzündung
entsteht die man aber sehr gut spürt und
auch sehr gut behandeln kann und aus den
daten von anderen ländern haben wir
keine rückmeldung dass dieses risiko
steigt nichtsdestotrotz wird man jetzt
natürlich sehr genau dieses szenario
beobachten ich würde aber trotzdem immer
dafür plädieren dass die risikogruppe 70
jetzt die dritte impfung bekommt vor
allem die sind sowieso gar nicht in also
sozusagen in einem risiko aufgetaucht
was diese herz geschichten anbetrifft
also würde man da nichts erwarten bei
autoimmunerkrankungen ist es so dass ich
gezeigt hat wenn man impft hat man quasi
das team corona das aktiv ist und die
autoimmunerkrankungen machen ein anderes
team und die sind getrennt voneinander
und gott sei dank gibt es da keine
querschläger sozusagen so dass man also
nicht erwarten muss das
autoimmunerkrankungen aufflackern durch
die impfung das hat auch die deutsche
gesellschaft für rheumatologie auch
nochmal bestätigt ist ein ganz wichtiger
punkt gut dass wir das auch noch mal
angesprochen haben marie und clark fragt
uns per facebook booster auch bei kreuz
impfungen astra und moderner es gibt
keine aufklärung darüber viele
pflegekräfte haben diese impfung
erhalten werden nun wieder alleine
gelassen so ihre meinung was können sie
dazu sagen ich
glaube sie war nicht allein gelassen
habe ist ein kommunikations thema
deswegen ist es gut dass es angesprochen
wird ich bin auch so eine
mix booster impfung sozusagen ich wusste
einfach nicht in form ich hatte erst
astrazeneca und dann den bayern tag
impfstoff das ist übrigens eine sehr
gute kombi das hat extrem gut
funktioniert in genau dieser ersten
vector impfstoff dann ein anna im stoff
und dadurch dass für die dritte impfung
dm-arena impfstoffe zugelassen sind ist
es gar nicht mehr relevant welche kombi
man vorher hatte das heißt die wirkt und
ist auch sicher egal ob man formal
vorher zweimal bei und tech oder m rna
zweimal vector oder eben erst vector und
dann eher männer hatte diese dritte
impfung basiert auf mrsa und ist
zugelassen oder empfohlen auch für alle
kombinationen und das ist dem
immunsystem ein bisschen egal was davor
war weil der impfstoff ist komplett
abgebaut und auch das protein dass wir
da gebastelt haben im körper es abgebaut
und da geht es sozusagen mit dieser
dritten impfung kommt nochmal ein neuer
m rna booster aber den interessiert
nicht mehr was vorher war insofern muss
man sich gar keine gedanken machen dass
es da unterschiede gebe sondern es ist
tatsächlich so wenn man die dritte
impfung empfiehlt bei den gruppen sollte
das funktionieren und tut es auch egal
was vorher war dann würde ich sie gerne
noch fragen mit welchem gefühl gehen sie
denn jetzt so insgesamt dem winter
entgegen wie gut ihre einschätzung nach
sind wir vorbereitet auf die situation
oder können sie vielleicht auch die
sorgen der derjenigen verstehen die
sagen ach jetzt gehen die zahlen wieder
so hoch das kann auch irgendwie alles
nicht wahr sein warum haben wir denn
dieses problem ist immer noch so an der
backe wie wie schätzen sie das insgesamt
ein
dass dieser gedanke das kann doch alles
nicht wahr sein denn habe ich auch es
ist so ich hätte nicht gedacht dass wir
mit dieser sehr guten und sicheren
impfung jetzt im november da stehen und
wir kommen nicht über diese
75% impfquote rüber das ist schon etwas
was mir echt zu denken gibt ich denke
wir müssen mehr aufklären wir müssen
alle fragen beantworten wir müssen
vertrauen schaffen durch transparenz und
wir müssen wirklich auch auf suchen.de
angebote noch mehr machen um die
menschen zu überzeugen sich bitte impfen
zu lassen es ist wirklich die aufgabe
die wir jetzt noch dringender haben als
die dritte auffrischimpfung weil wir
wirklich die gruppe der geimpften
dringend erhöhen sollten wenn wir das
schaffen kommen wir auch besser in
diesem winter ein moment haben wir
steigende zahlen weil so viele menschen
geimpft sind wenn wir da noch schaffen
ein bisschen mehr motivation zu
erreichen wäre mir das ein ganz
wichtiges anliegen parallel dazu sollten
wir die leute schützen die ihn jetzt
eine auffrischimpfung brauchen und die
risiko und wo in der alle gruppen sind
und wir sollten auf jeden fall
gemeinschaftlich sozusagen dessen
bewusst sein dass wir gerade sehr viel
virus in der gesellschaft haben und
abstand hygiene und masten also aha plus
lüften plus testen kann uns gerade sehr
gut helfen besser durch den herbst
winter zu kommen das sollte unsere
gemeinschaftliche idee sein dass hier
die zahlen besser unter kriegen weil
dann ist alles einfacher weil wir haben
ja heute und aus der politik gehört es
wird schon damit überlegt dass man
andere regelungen vielleicht noch
überlegen muss und da wäre es am
einfachsten zu sagen mit abstand maske
hygienemaßnahmen lüften und testen
kommen wir schon sehr sehr weit es gibt
ganz viele vernünftige menschen die sich
haben impfen lassen wenn wir jetzt
wieder zusammen halten kriegen wir das
ganz gut in den griff und deswegen ist
es ein dringender appell an die leute
die noch nicht geimpft sind sich
vielleicht doch ein herz zu fassen und
sich eine impfung geben zu lassen ein
schönes schlusswort christine falk war
das präsidentin der deutschen
gesellschaft für immunologie vielen dank
dass sie heute abend es da für uns zur
verfügung gestanden haben und dass sie
so sympathisch und kompetent und
aufgeklärt haben dankeschön dafür ich
danke ihnen schön abend dankeschön ja
auch an euch natürlich ganz lieben dank
für die zahlreichen zuschriften bzw
fragen und kommentare die uns erreicht
haben unmöglich alle dran zu nehmen aber
ich denke wir konnten einige abarbeiten
wie gesagt vielen dank wir wünschen euch
einen schönen abend und verabschieden
uns für heute bis zum nächsten